[Music]
all right hello everybody welcome to
chest openings explained
i'm your instructor tonight nick risco
one of the instructors here at the trust
club and tonight we're going to be
looking at
a very powerful opening for black it is
the marshall attack also known as the
marshall gambit
where in the main line of the ruilope
has black decides to sacrifice a pawn
for some
insane king side attack now this is
a very heavily analyzed opening so there
is a lot of theory on it but lucky for
us
it's pretty straightforward it's not
going to be too wide there's a couple
main variations that uh
black would need to to know if they're
playing the marshall
or that white can choose from we're
going to be looking at it from
white's perspective tonight
and let's get right into it so here we
start off
with e4 e5 knight f3
knight c6 and bishop to b5 like i said
this isn't the rui lopez
so we're going to be going about 10
moves deep into the uh
i guess eight moves deep into the rui
theory before we see the marshall attack
we see
a6 which is the morphe defense and then
white retreats the bishop to a4
uh they want to maintain pressure on
this knight to possibly capture
and then win the pawn on e5 later can't
get away with it now though due to uh
to some counter play that black can get
but we're not going to be focusing on
those lines this is about the marshall
gambit
we're going to be going knight f6
castles bishop to e7
rookie 1 b5 bishop b3
castles pawn to c3
and here we kind of have our our
starting point
i do want to mention white does not need
to play c3 here
c3 plays directly into the marshall
attack
if white wants to avoid all of this um
they could play something like pawn to
a4 here pawn to h3 is playable
but c3 does give into black's plans here
normally you will see black play pawn to
d6 and after pawn to d6
there is no martial attack so c3 makes
sense and then you'll see black castle
and then whites can play h3 this is the
main line for the closed
defenses but after castling first
black is leaving the option for after c3
to go with the move pawn to d5 striking
in the center
and giving up a pawn right away
and it would make sense for white to to
win this pawn here
by white playing c3 first
they really say i'm okay with the
martial attack so they should really
just capture
the capture on d5 black captures with
the knight and here's where the pawn
falls
knight takes e5 knight takes e5 and rook
takes e5
okay so here black is down upon what
does he have to show
for it well this uh original idea
came from the game capablanca marshall
new york 1918 and we have gone over this
game on the youtube channel before but i
believe it was all the way back
and um i think it was 2016. so it's been
a while since we've gone over it i'm not
going to cover the game
jonathan shawn's already had a good
lecture on it but
um the idea that marshall had the
original in the original game is to go
knight f6
and after something like rookie 1 bishop
to d6 and immediately start attacking
the king's side
white would go h3 and prevent
the the knight from coming in but it
turns out the knight can go in anyway
and if you try and spend the time to
capture something like queen h4
is going to be very deadly but that's as
deep as i'm going to go into the
original ideas
that game kappa actually just decided to
to blow marshall off the board
finding a critical d4 push and because
of the d4 push in that game
knight to f6 has been shown not to be
the best move in this position
and over time players have discovered
that c6
is the best move here the idea behind c6
is pretty simple
black is spending a tempo to stabilize
the knight in the center
here on d5 and then preparing to play
bishop to d6 on the next move attacking
white's rook
so here white is down in development you
know this knight on d5 is very good the
bishop on e7
well placed the queen is ready to fly in
after the bishop goes to d6 this
bishop's ready to come to g4
so white really needs to play actively
and make sure that
they can develop their pieces in time to
defend this great attack
so the main move here is pawn to d4
i believe recently maybe not so recently
but uh pawn to d3 has been an idea we're
not going to cover that tonight
i don't have the time to get to it but
there's a lot of critical stuff after
pawn to d4
that's going to take up our entire
lecture anyway
and after pawn to d4 black's plan very
straightforward
bishop to d6 now black needs to make
sure they play very actively here if
they don't play actively and play some
other developing moves something like
i guess bishop to e6 looks natural
enough but if black just goes too slow
white is going to be able to catch up in
the development here
after something like knight to d2 the
knight will go to f3
or f1 and then the bishop will develop
and then white's just
going to be up a pawn for practically
nothing
so again black needs to play very
actively the most active move here is
bishop to d6
again attacking the rook and opening up
the path for the queen to come to h4
now here the most popular move is rook
to e1
and i agree that rook to e1 is probably
the best try although
black should be aware that rook e2 has
been played before just trying to
make sure that your second rank is kind
of stabilized
okay and i'm hearing we are going live
on twitch now too
so if there are any questions on twitch
i will be checking that chat
as well uh so welcome twitch viewers
uh okay so after rook to e1 we get the
uh the critical queen two
h4 now black should involve the queen in
the attack pretty early on
um generally you'll hear from your
coaches
or instructors don't move the queen out
too early in the opening
but this is one of those exceptions it's
actually not that early in the opening
if you look at black's development
the only piece that hasn't been added to
the attack yet is this light square
bishop
and it can't really go anywhere without
support from the queen anyway
this bishop does want to go to g4 and
you can't go there currently because of
the queen so this queen to h4 idea
not only is it threatening a mating
attack by putting pressure on h2
but you're also building support for
this bishop on c8
so again black should involve the queen
early
and then what black is going to be
trying to do is push this f pawn
add more pressure now white's plans are
going to be trying to
stop this mating attack from black which
can be done with a series of precise
moves
and then uh later on they're going to
try and play a4
and open up the queen side try and get
some counter play over there
now quantum head in the chat's asking uh
can you just play
g3 and yes g3 is actually the only move
in this position here
to stop the mate threat these pawns are
going to create
a nice blockade for this bishop
and after pawn to g3 actually let's talk
about what happens if you don't play g3
um some people might be inclined to play
pawn to h3
which is a blunder here actually it
looks like you're stopping this mate on
h2 and
temporarily you are however again
with black being up so far up in
development they're actually able to get
away with bishop takes
h3 here and now if you try
taking this bishop on h3 the queen is
going to take on h3 and your king's side
is just completely wrecked
your king is completely exposed and
after some more moves black's going to
be in a winning position
i believe the best moves for both sides
are going to go rook to e5
you're gonna have to sacrifice the
exchange to stay alive
so uh oops captures on d5 cap
sorry on e5 capture on e5 and rook a to
e8
just putting pressure on the pawn this
rook a to e8 is gonna be a very common
move for black
often times it's just going to be an
automatic move black can usually get
away with playing it without even
thinking
so rick8 and then captures on d5
uh you don't want to go with the queen
it's going to be removing the queen from
the action
if you try and go queen takes d5 then
just rook to d8 and the rook is going to
come to d1 on the next move
so can't take on d5 you really need to
be developing your pieces
we'll see the bishop go to f4 to
reinforce the center
and now rook e6 and the rook is going to
be
swinging over to g6 we see knight d2
rook g6 bishop g3 and after pawn to f5
i think black is just going to have a
crushing position this pawn is going to
make its way to f4
and white's going to lose the bishop on
g3 if you try and take with on passant
then just rook takes g3 right away after
the pawn takes
queen takes the king has to go somewhere
you don't want to go to the f file
because rook takes so after king to h1
just queen h3 king g1 and now rook takes
f6
is going to be death for white
you have to go queen h3 check first if
you take on f6
right away there's actually the queen h5
that's going to
help save this position if black tries
something like rook h6
then white can actually get away with
taking the rook
and then going rook g1 pinning the queen
to the king and now is actually white
who's winning
so you need to make sure that uh if
you're black you're inserting this queen
h3 check
first otherwise you're you're gonna find
yourself in an equal or worse position
but after queen h3
black is just winning here so
you can't go pawn to h3 you have to go
pawn to g3 to stop this mating attack
so um yes quantum head uh that line did
look terrible for white as they were
losing however that's not the main line
we're gonna show how white can survive
this attack
so after pawn to g3 the queen is
attacked black has to do something about
it they can't just sacrifice the queen
and the most popular move you'll find
here is queen to h3
and the idea of queen to h3 is so that
way
you can go bishop to g4 attacking the
queen
and then go bishop f3 and then you're
threatening made on g2
so white needs to be aware of this
threat and watch out
what happens so here there's
two different ideas that white has i'm
gonna go over
what is known as the main line first
bishop to e3
and then uh at the end we're going to go
over maybe a more critical
rook to e4 so this is kind of where we
get our first real
fork in our theory here
up to this point on up to move 15
everything's been rather
forced so it's been pretty
straightforward not
too much that uh you know white has to
choose from
so here we'll look at bishop to e3 and
some of you guys who like your bishop
pair might be wondering why are you
offering
your bishop up for trade but really what
this uh what this bishop is doing is
really just helping to
secure your position solidify and also
you want to make sure you can develop
this knight to d2 to come to f1
and also help secure the position now
the problem with going to
knight to d2 here first is you block in
this bishop
now this bishop isn't going to have any
influence over the game on g5
in fact black can just play something
like h6 and kick it away
right away so e3 is the best square
for this bishop and now
we will see white or sorry black
continue with their plan of bishop to
g4 attacking the queen and again the
idea is going to be going to
f3 to threaten mate on g2
so we'll take a brief moment here sandro
shock in the chats asking if 9e4
will also be discussed so if black plays
e4
i'm unaware of that line so i'll take a
look into it but
as of tonight we're not going to be
looking at that line
so here in this position bishop uh goes
to g4
after this move white again only has one
move that they can play
and that move is queen to d3 now this
looks a little awkward
uh now we were just talking about moving
the knight to d2
but after something like knight to d2
you're just hanging your queen
so you have to move your queen you can't
just block with f3
blocking with f3 is going to throw the
game away
after bishop takes g3 and now there is
no good move for white
black is threatening to take on h2 and
just take all your pawns on the king
side and
whether or not you get mated you're
going to be down down some material
and not survive you're too far behind in
development
there isn't even a main line after here
f3 you can resign but queen to d3
the idea is the queen is always keeping
an eye on the f1 square
that way if something like bishop to f3
you have the move queen to f1 and this
is the only move that will stop the mate
threat
if you try anything else like uh if you
capture
not even capture if you try and just go
knight d2 just mating one so
this is the idea behind queen to d3
again no other move is going to work
here you're either going to hang your
queen or hang mates so like if queen d2
bishop f3 no way to stop the mate in one
so you have to go
queen to d3 and this idea of the queen
coming to f1
exists in almost all of the lines for
for uh whites now we're getting the
question
what happens if the knight takes on e3
anytime the knight takes on e3 white
just captures with the rook and they're
not gaining anything out of it
the capture with the f pawn is not
forced if they did capture with the f
pawn
this will lead to severe trouble after
bishop takes g3
and you can't just take back because the
queen g3 after king f1
uh your king is just too exposed it
can't run to e2
just something like rook a to e8 you
lift the rook
probably not to e6 because of the bishop
but
you just lift the rook and bring it over
what black is going to win this game
so any knight captures on e3 white will
be happy to capture with the rook
knight to d2 and then bring the other
rook to e1 and
catch up in development rather quickly
so taking on e3 i'm not going to
recommend it for black
okay after queen to d3 what does black
have
well here they just bring in another
piece to the attack
rook a to e8 and like i said this move
is going to be very common for black in
most
most positions it can just be played
automatically
so rook a to e8 and then here there's
a couple ideas for white um
but i think white's best move is just
knight to d2
trying to catch up in development black
has not made a real threat with rook
a to e8 so you actually do get this move
to
help finish up your development with
knight to d2
so danny zabayan is mentioning that
you can lift the rook to e6 and yeah
it's skipping in my mind that if the
bishop captures you capture with the f
pawn and the other rook is staring at
you in the position
that we were just talking about um but
okay knight d2
and then rook to e6 is the main move
here there is an alternative that we
will get to
is queen to h5 and you go queen h5 first
um now why is
black not going bishop to f3 well the
idea is that
white does have this mate threat covered
and black doesn't really want to trade
queens
after forcing um queen to f1
uh they're not going to really benefit
from something like queen h5
right away and then white's always going
to have this mate threat covered so it's
giving up some of your play as black so
that's why they don't go bishop f3 you
see rook a to e8
knight d2 and now rook to e6 again
queen h5 is an alternative here and here
best move for white it looks like a4 is
playable here
and white can start getting their play
on the queen side rather early on and
now after rook to e6 you capture on b5
black takes back otherwise you're going
to be down to pawn and after queen to f1
the position holds
if you go queen f1 first black does have
a
what looks to be mysterious at first a
rook e7 move
after rook e7 white can actually play f3
and try and mess up black's pieces make
sure they're not coordinated
after captures on e3 looks like you're
giving up a piece but
queen to f2 and both pieces are hanging
you have to give up one you can't save
both and you'll trade off some rooks and
white will be able to trade off some
pieces and at least make sure that
you're not getting mated the end game
might not be as
good for white this is going to be the
type of end game you're looking at
here again probably not going to be
much better for white most engines are
saying this is
equal or better for black but you're not
getting mated this is going to be an end
game you can go for
but that's if you go queen f1 first i
think you just go a4 you'll be fine
but uh like i said this is the sideline
the main move here
is rook to e6 um
and let's see danny's asking what is
white's plan
for a pawn he stays passive all game i
actually have to disagree with you white
is not being passive here
white is actually very active and active
enough to make sure they can stop the
mate threats
uh just because you have only moves i
would not say that that
is being passive this position is very
active for both sides it's not like
white is making moves just to
to move and pass past the move to black
they're stopping black's threats
while also giving chances for them to
have play later on
it just so happens black also has only
moves that are able to stop white's
counter play
so i don't think that that they're being
passive at all here
okay so after rook to e6 what does white
do there is queen to f1 here as well and
going queen to f1 here
first isn't horrible black just moves
the queen away and then refuses to trade
queens this is
another common idea for black the queen
coming to h5 and there's a couple
purposes for going to h5
over something like h6 one of the main
reasons is that you uh
you keep this pair together so they can
help each other out on this diagonal but
the other
reason maybe a little more important is
that if there's ever a capture on d5
the queen can actually recapture and
black doesn't have to compromise their
pawn structure here on c6
so queen to h5 and now again we see a4
and then an f3 idea so a lot of these
ideas are
very similar in most of these lines and
it looks like we're getting something
like a transposition
from the other position i think white's
just a little bit farther ahead in their
development because black had to play
bishop to b8 in this line
but queen f1 is not the main move i
think white should just be active and go
for the counter play right away on the
queen side
they really can't make any moves on the
king side that would compromise their
king safety
so you have to play somewhere else you
can't really play in the center because
black's pieces are pretty active and
stopping any pushes on c4
so the only side of the board left is
the queen side and you go pawn a4
and this is where white gets that
counter play
to try and get pressure against black's
position
where this is why i can't agree with uh
some in the chat who are saying white's
being very passive
we see queen to h5 and this is
anticipating queen to f1
just so that way after queen to f1 they
don't have to move so they're kind of
saving a tempo with this
and then again over defending d5 that
way
the pawns will be clean you don't have
to make any compromises
see ab5 ab5
and here white's pretty safe now they've
survived the
the king side attack and now have a
multitude of options
to continue the main line here is
knight to f1 and after knight to f1
you'll see bishop to f5 attacking the
queen
after queen d2 we see bishop h3
attacking the knight
this is no big deal white has bishop to
d1
getting a tempo on the queen so the
queen has to move
and really the only move for the queen
is bishop to g6 the bishops control
all the other squares and now bishop to
f3 again looking at this knight thinking
of maybe coming to g2 and trading off
the bishops not a horrible idea
queen to f5 just putting pressure on the
bishop and now instead of just trading
for the night
this would uh be very bad after queen
takes
excuse me they're threatening mate again
instead of inviting mate
um they just bring the queen back and
defend the bishop
now black can still add on to this
attack white is not
out of the woods just yet they can try
with something like pawn to h5
after pawn to h5 the idea is trying to
go to
h4 we have a question does black have
f5 and f4 instead of bishop f5 we'll
take a look at that in just a second
rook a6 does put pressure on the sixth
rank and bishop to c7 is kind of forced
so black can protect the c pawn
and now after bishop to h1 you're trying
to make sure your queen can move around
right now your queen is pinned to the
defense of the bishop so you save your
bishop
and now rook f6 pressure on f2 but it's
defended by
the bishop we see queen to e2 over
defending f2 because knight takes e3 as
a threat
pawn to h4 trying to break through
bishop d2 opening the line
for white sandra shock saying we're
already at move 20 we're actually almost
at move 30 here
um rick to e6 queen to f3
and the idea is you want to trade off
the queens make sure that you can get
rid of some of the firepower that black
has
so you trade on e1 and now bishop to
f4 a very surprising move if you've
never seen it
can you take the pawn on h5 no i don't
believe you can
we'll also take a look at that in a
second i want to make sure we get
through
the the main line here here with the
main line that actually results in a
draw surprisingly
but we'll take a look at bishop f4 here
you cannot take because
after takes there's queen g6 and then
knight g3 is forced to protect if you go
bishop g2
there's knight takes f4 and there's too
many pieces on g2 that you're going to
lose
one of your main defenders so
taking the bishop is just a little bit
of a trick that black has
you can go bishop g2 and here's where we
get uh
closer to our draw with bishop to g4
black
being the attacker doesn't want to trade
off their attacking pieces
and now white has queen to e4 again
not wanting to trade off attacking
pieces we see queen to c8 attacking the
rook
so rook has to go back to a1 probably
the best square just kind of keep an eye
on the back rank here
rip to e8 attacking the queen and now we
see queen to c2 now there are other
moves here if white wants to continue
the game like queen to d3
queen to b1 even but the idea is going
to be pretty much
the same the bishop goes to f5 and after
queen to d1
bishop to g4 and you get a repetition of
moves here
after queen c2 and bishop to f5 and
many draws have happened here just based
off of this repetition
i believe if both players know 40 moves
of theory
i i don't think asking for draws too
much
however again white can continue the
game with something like queen b3 here
still even position it's just um
yeah this is going to be the position
you have to play and study for if you
want to play on
but okay we did have some questions in
the youtube chat here
first it looks like we had
to do after they play h5 so we'll work
our way backwards here
uh so what is this queen to d1 and pawn
to h5
can you take the problem with taking
here
seems to be rook to f6 whenever now
knight to e3 is a threat because then f2
will hang
so you have to play something like queen
to e2 but after queen to e2
you have another rook entering the fight
on the e-file
and it looks like all this pressure is
going to mount in a uh
attack that white cannot cannot survive
from if you try and make a move here
like what if we try rook a6 and try and
get that pressure on the sixth rank
again
upon the g6 attacking the bishop there
seems to be nowhere for the bishop to go
and your bishop's trapped
so that seems to be the problem with
taking if you tried queen to d2
then your bishop just hangs so it looks
like your bishop's just getting
trapped if you're taking on h5
which is why we're seeing rook to a6
instead
and leaving the bishop on f3 so it can
tuck away on h1 but very good question
why can't we take
the other question we had in the youtube
chat was uh
instead of bishop to f5 does black have
f5
and f4 and i believe
they do
let's see bishop f5 on this move i guess
uh let's see if they try f5 trying to go
for f4 i guess
this can be shut down with bishop to f4
if you're worried about the knight
taking you can capture on d5 first so
like bishop takes and then pawn takes
and bishop f4
and now if bishop takes just uh rook
takes e6
so you'll see rookie one rookie one now
bishop f4
and after gf you're actually pretty safe
your queen
or your knight can come to g3 most
likely the queen to save the position
here tie up loose suns with the pawns
and white just is safe black can't
checkmate with
the bishop and queen alone and then
there's really no clear path for this
rook to get
into the game so i think it's it's
interesting it's worth a try but i think
in that specific position
it doesn't work because of bishop f4
there are other lines
where black does get to play f5
early on but i don't think i have any of
the early f5 moves covered
okay i want to take a look at one of our
other forks in the position here
after ab5 and ab5 now knight f1 like i
said
is the main move but once i looked into
it more it looks like it's a pretty
not a force to draw like white can still
play but
a very equal position where black gets a
lot of activity
i think after knight f1 a very
interesting idea that could be better
i'm not saying that a 100 is better
but one idea that i find very attractive
is knight to e4 and this is a less
popular move but it's been played at
some of the higher levels here
and can run into some some very
interesting things happening in the
center here
so knight e4 you're looking at the
bishop on d6 if you can capture this
bishop
then i think you'll be okay because then
you don't need to worry about sacrifices
on g3 anymore
now here black does have bishop to f5
and what this move does is it pins the
knight
to the queen and this can be a bit of a
problem here
as just capturing on d6 you end up
losing your queen
so you have to do something about this
currently the knight is hanging
so we see bishop to d2 and the idea is
you're dropping the bishop back
and opening up the file for the rook to
recapture
and here black has a very interesting
way to capture
i might give the chat a little bit of
time to find it and we'll hop over to
the
twitch chat real quick and see if
there's any questions over there that i
missed
um okay let's see
looks like one of the questions here is
is it reasonable to refuse the marshall
gambit that's what you feel like you
should do
i feel like it's more than reasonable
some players some very strong players i
believe kasparov included
made sure that their opponent could
never play the martial attack
i myself i don't play c3 and allow it
so if you don't want to face the
marshall gambit there are ways to get
out of it but that requires you to
do some move order things or play the
anti-martial with a4
which we might cover in the future maybe
next week i'm thinking about it
but tonight's about the marshall we're
not talking about the anti-martial
but definitely reasonable to refuse the
marshall
if you feel like you can't remember
proper defense
okay looks like we're all caught up but
here the move for black the only one
where black is uh
really keeping any hopes of an advantage
here
is rook takes e4 now you would probably
think
bishop captures e4 because
it looks like you're giving up a rook
after but here after rick takes e4
rookie four and queen e4
white is actually winning this position
because black has traded off all their
firepower here
white has the bishop pair that's staring
down the board
they're up a healthy center pawn and the
rook is ready to come into a6
or a7 and white has has curved the
attack
so instead of bishop e4 we see rook e4
and the idea here is that after rook
takes e4
white does not actually capture right
away so again if they capture right away
we just transpose and black is losing
but here if you keep the pin you can
actually put pressure on
this rook and just win the full rook
back
starting with queen to g6 so queen to g6
just adds on to this pin
here now it's reasonable to play f3
and defend it that way if they do
capture you can retake with pawn
and then you're going to get some pawns
rolling down the center
um and here we see knight to f6 just
adding another attacker now you can't
just move
the rook if you just move the rook then
they take your queen
so now we do reach a position where
white has to move the queen
out of danger queen to f1 just letting
black take on e4
which is fine i mean you won the
exchange on e4 you're just giving it
back
when you're up material like that you do
have the leisure of being able to give
it
up that way you can save your position
and here bishop takes e4
but here after something like bishop to
f4 this is really the only way to get
this bishop active in the game with your
pawns on b2 c3 and d4
and it looks like white's winning like
they're up a pawn it's a center pawn but
it's more of an illusion this pawn on
its own
is not enough to win with both sides
having both bishops
they're going to be able to have that
scope and range to be able to protect
whatever pawn is passed and then just be
able to trade off a piece for the pawn
after most of the other pieces are
traded off
but here after bishop to f4
something like bishop d3 attacking the
queen queen f2
bishop takes queen takes this is a
completely
equal position engines give triple zeros
really just maneuver your pieces forever
if you're trying to win here
so that is one of the lines
there after queen to f1
um queen f1 is fine i think another move
here
is actually queen to e3 and this has
also been played
sorry um they were saying white is not
up a pawn that's correct sorry
um i meant up a pawn in the center um
because black did have three on the
king's side white only had two
but i meant up at center pawn so i
apologize
so after queen to e3 something like um
uh bishop takes e4 is possible
uh and after fe4 then just knight e4
and again you're gonna have this equal
almost end game
but black has an interesting bishop to
g3 if they're trying to draw right away
you don't really want to take if you
take just queen takes g3 and now you get
a repetition of
king h1 and queen h3 or if you try going
to f1
there's queen h2 trapping your king on
the first rank
and now after i don't know what move you
want to play here
you try playing like rook to uh c1 or
something
you're going to lose your exchange back
and then bishop
to h3 your king is forced to e1
and now bishop g4 trapping the king in
and you're going to get a perpetual with
the queen on h1 and h2
so bishop takes g3 is a force draw so
knight e4
definitely possible um but after bishop
to f5 you do need to be careful
that you're not just losing this you
need to remember bishop to d2
and then black does have some kind of
force draws
in the end game there but i think this
is also a
an interesting way to play one that your
opponent may not be expecting because
knight f1 is just played much more
but that is that's kind of what i wanted
to look at with our main line here
with um bishop to e3 so now we're going
to take the rest of our time here
i'll double check the chat for any more
questions about the bishop e3 lines
before we move on to rick e4
we'll check twitch here nothing's
happening in twitch chat
youtube sometime here
all right i'm not seeing anything coming
in so we are
going to move on here so
we're gonna move back um we'll actually
go back to the beginning
for a refresh refresher i know twitch
missed the beginning here but
uh e4 e5 knight f3 knight c6 bishop b5
a6 bishop a4 knight f6
castles bishop e7 rookie 1 b5 bishop b3
castles c3 all standard roy lopez theory
and then d5 white should take
after black takes take on e5 pawn to c6
to stabilize
d4 to make sure you can develop in time
bishop d6
rookie 1 queen h4 pawn g3
and queen h3 this is our main position
we just looked at the bishop to e3 lines
but the other alternative one that has
i guess been a little on the rise here
is rook to e4 and the main idea here is
you want to go rook to h4 and just make
sure that queen is never on the h
file that seems to be where black has
their queen most of the time in the
bishop e3 lines
and the idea with rookie 4 is simply
rook h4 get the queen off of there
however black has a very nice move here
pawn to g5 pawn to g5 is actually going
to stop this idea
but there is a trade-off for it so the
idea of
pawn to g5 is that uh again you're
stopping the rook over
and if white tries to just take this
pawn
they're going to be losing immediately
after queen to f5
forking the rook and bishop and if you
try something like rick g4 trying to
save it
just queen g4 anyway sorry not queen g4
sorry not queen g5 you go queen g4
because the queen is backed up by the
bishop
so you're losing a piece here if you
take with the bishop so white has to
look for some
other moves there's been a couple tries
here
um the two main ones we're going to look
at is queen to f3
and queen to f1 queen f1 is the main
line here
but i'm also going to address knight d2
because knight d2 does look
natural you are behind in development on
the queen side so you want to catch up
however after knight to d2 this is a
little
too slow here and black gets to play the
move
f5 and start attacking right away
uh you pretty much have to go rook to e3
here if you go rook to e1
um this is just a little too slow the
pawn goes to f4
and black is breaking through so rook to
e3
the knight cannot capture because of
this pin
so we will see this slow move
from black here king to h8
it's very important to remember king h8
this is what gives black the flexibility
to
have this attack because again of that
pin on the knight
if black tries to go with f4 immediately
they can run into a little bit of
trouble white does have some very active
defense here after capturing with the g
pawn and you cannot simply capture back
because of rook
takes h3 so you have to move your queen
to safety
probably queen to h6 here and then
after knight to e4 you're attacking d6
and g5 so we see bishop to f4
just stopping both of those threats and
now after rook to g3
you're giving up the exchange that way
after h takes
you have a very solid position and
you've curved this
big attack now the way black would try
to probably continue here
is either queen to g6 attacking the
loose knight
or rook to a7 hoping to bring it over to
the f-file but white is going to have
enough time to play
a4 and get that counter play on the
queen side that we've been seeing
throughout all these lines but
f4 black doesn't need to uh let white
get so much
play they just go king h8 very slow and
then
able to to move the knight around in the
future
now this threat on the rook is real if
you try and go rookie one here
again way too slow f4 is just going to
tear your position apart so
more accurate
is rook to d3 but even after rook to d3
just pawn f4 black is going to be
busting through
so it's really hard to see what what
exactly
white can play here to survive after f4
again
just a little slow something like queen
f1 trying to trade
queen h84 bishop h3 attacking the queen
queen moves to safety after bishop c7
saving the bishop from the knights trade
trade on d5 and knight c5 after the
automatic cricket
ea it's it's like what what moves does
white have the bishop's completely stuck
this rook is completely stuck uh with
this rook not
sorry this bishop not being able to
develop this rook is stuck your queen
can't just go to f1 like you would like
it to do
white's pieces have nowhere to go
so this knight d2 line is pretty much
busted it is too slow
after pawn to f5
so if knight d2 isn't playable you do
want to go to that other idea that you
may have
which is to make sure you can trade off
the attacking pieces so we have
queen to f1 and queen to f3
we'll look at queen to f3 here the idea
is dropping back on g2 and getting a
trade that way
this runs into bishop f5 which attacks
the rook right away
and here if you try rookie one
again rookie one in most of these lines
is going to be too slow after rook a to
e8 offering a trade
white is just too far behind in
development
if you take you look at all the black's
pieces all of the pieces are developed
and white's queen side is just sad it's
very sad over here nothing's developed
you're not going to be able to save your
entire position with just a queen
the rook is going to be coming to e1
this bishop is ready to come to e4
and what that is is kind of skewering
or pinning a queen and a mating square
so very rough position for white instead
of trying to save the rook you should
just give up the exchange
or try the interesting bishop takes d5
here
bishop takes d5 and now they take on d5
now you have some time to save your rook
on e3
most commonly you'll see bishop to e4
and again the idea is just
uh if you move your queen away then
you're going to get mated on g2 so you
have to give up the exchange here
differences now you get the center pawn
along with it or
queen to f6 getting some really nice
counter play on the bishop
and the pawn and here
uh one of the only moves to to really
save black's position here from the
counter play is queen to g4
and this move is not obvious to most
people i would assume
because it looks like you're just
hanging the bishop but
black does have this very nice threat of
coming to d1
and then taking on c1 and the idea well
to a beginner it may look like it's just
a trade of bishops this is far more than
just a trade of bishops
your queen is going to come in on that
first rank and pin your knight on b1 to
the rook on a1
so your knight on b1 will never be able
to develop
that means that knight will never be in
the game and if that knight cannot
develop
your rook on a1 is going to be stuck
there unless you can play
a4 trade off the a pawn and open up the
a file
but even then your rook is stuck to a1
protecting the knight on b1 so taking
this bishop on d6
is a very bad move for white here
because of queen d1 you're just never
going to be able to develop your queen
side pieces
and this pawn on e4 is going to run
forward you're going to probably trade
off your f
pawn and then black's just going to
shove their f pawn up the board and
we don't want to have to deal with that
so don't take on d6 instead
there is uh i think a couple moves here
you have um queen takes g5
which trades off the queens and this is
forcing you're going to be able to play
knight d2
but this is going to be rather equal
after pawn to f5
knight d2 and you can move your knight
to f1 and e3
but there's nothing really great
here you do have this past d-pawn but
black does have their pawns further up
the board and they can
again open up your king side just
white's been a little too far behind in
development
here i think better better than just
trading off the queens right away
is knight to d2 first leave the queen on
the board make sure you retain some
counter play
get your pieces developed secure your
position
you have rook 88 protecting the pawn
now we see a take on d6 and the idea of
this bishop sacrifice is to play pawn to
e3
and white cannot casually capture back
on e3 because rook takes e3
and now you're going to be seeing like a
rook to e2 type of idea
you can see rook takes g3 being an idea
if the queen moves
if we try something like knight f1 just
rook to e1
and again we have this idea where
everything is just
pinned on the first rank nothing can
develop
so very very sad here don't take on e3
with the pawn
um you just go knight to f3 and the
the sad part is like white has to give
the piece back to save their position
but after knight f3 this should just be
fine for whites if queen takes f3
the idea is that bishop takes on e3
and while you may be looking at this
bishop like it's just a tall pawn
that kind of the point it's making sure
your position is secure
making sure that nothing can really just
bust through right away
black can sacrifice the exchange if they
would like
white can just go king to h1 and
check forever if you're not going to
check forever something like
queen to f2 uh now queen two d5 hitting
the pawn
and also ready to come back to g2 and
this should be a rather
um even end game because black does have
the checks i don't think white
white is just going to be able to simply
run the d-pawn up the board
but it's definitely going to be black
who's playing for the draw here
so instead of sacrificing the exchange
here it's not necessary
you can get counter play on the queen
with rook to e6
and after rook to e6 queen has to move
so queen c5 is the only real safe square
for the queen
and pawn to h6 and this position is
rather balanced
black just needs to be careful not to go
with the direct f5
this is a mistake because this does give
white the time
to push the pawn to d5 and now you can't
just
block with the rook you have to move the
rook to um
to safety here so something like rookie
five trying to pin it maybe
but now bishop to d4 and
you can't just take on d5 if you take on
d5 you have a
queen to c6 move here or queen to e7 is
probably
a little bit cleaner you're looking to
checkmate on g7 you're also hitting this
pawn on g5
and there's no way for black to save
both and
here white does have a crushing
advantage to these dual threats
so as long as you're black if you're
playing black make sure you don't play a
five here
play something like h6 and solidify your
position instead
and then you're going to be up in
exchange in return white is going to
have this past pawn
leads to a very interesting endgame
so see in the youtube chat here
so this is all exhausted and seen all
lines go to a draw alas is white why
would he get into this opening if it
draws the outcome
so very good question um we are actually
here
near the end of our theory um
i'll cover the queen to f1 line real
quick and then i'll get back to that
question
queen to f1 here we'll go back to our
main position after g5
this is our last line here queen to
f1 which is the main line black avoids
this trade of queens and goes queen h5
the idea we've seen all night long
knight to d2 bishop to f5 hitting the
rook
you give up the exchange black doesn't
take right away if they take right away
then f takes e4 actually leads to a
better position for white
a very nice pawn center the knight
probably has to go back to b6 and now
after e5 this bishop
is forced to go to e7 and he goes back
the other way just staring at pawns
forever so you have to go to e7
and now queen g2 in the position is safe
for white
they're gonna go knight e4 or knight f3
and then bishop d2 and bring the rook
over to f1
very easy development so instead of
taking right away
we go knight f6 trying to get it with an
advantage
queen to g2 queen to g6 just piling up
on e4
and now rook to e3 if you try taking
here again just um actually i think here
knight takes is better
but it's hard to see like where it's
black's advantage here the queen is
saving the king side
and then um unites getting counter play
bishop comes to d2
very quickly followed by rook to e1
so after queen g2 rookie 3 sorry knight
to sorry queen g6 rook e3
knight d5 hitting the rook we see a
trade on d5 this
makes sense here normally you're not
going to trade your bishop for that
knight
but here it would make sense because you
just moved your rook to e3
you don't want to just give the tempo by
going back to e1
now the knight goes to b3 it's going to
look to go to c5 and the bishop comes to
d2 and he double rooks
rook a to c8 kind of stopping this
knight c5 idea because it would hang
upon
bishop d2 rook after e8 you protect with
the queen
you can also go rook a to e1
and this will also get you a desired
result but i think here i just looked at
queen to f2
upon h6 and you'll see
this is going to be kind of the ideas
for both sides
white's going to get their knight on c5
it's now able to stay there because the
queen's on f2
that's why queen f2 is played instead of
rook at e1
and both sides are going to try and
expand their pawns on opposite sides of
the board
but here white still needs to be careful
of attacks by black but this is going to
be
the kind of end game you get queen
bishop and rook versus queen bishop rook
and various assortment of pawns
so we did have the um the question
in the youtube chat from danny that um
it seems like all this theory is
exhausted and all the lines lead to a
draw
so why would white opt to go
for this line um why would i be
talking about this lecture if i you know
thought that white shouldn't play this
well one
it's very good for both sides to know
white doesn't want to just fall into
this trap right away
not really a trap but this is also
probably one of if not
the most sound gambit in chess other
than you know the queen's gambits this
is one of the most sound gambits for
black it has not been refuted most of
these lines do go to a draw
so if black is a gambit player this is
good to play but i think
the real reason why i want to show this
is i think it's good for
any beginner amateur who wants to get
better
at well from the white side defending
your position well
and from the black side getting very
serious
attacking chances you know no kid at a
scholastic tournament is going to have
40 moves
of martial theory memorized if they're
white
unless they're like a super high rated
kid
so it's very easy for white to go wrong
white has to play very precisely
there are some lines some of these end
games where
one side would hold a slight advantage
over the others that could also be
another reason
to go for them is you're planning to
play one of the sidelines
which has less theory hope to catch your
opponent off guard and get an advantage
there but i think this is just a
very strong attack by black that both
sides should be aware of
and like i said bla or sorry white
totally does not need
to allow this to happen if this if you
think it is a draw
um this is not forced again
um all the way back after black castles
first i would say about
i don't want to throw a statistic out
there because i'm sure i'll get it wrong
but if they cancel first i would say
most of the time they're planning on
going d5 again
you don't have to play c3 here c3 is
what lets black play the marshall attack
playing moves like h3 and a4 those are
anti-martial moves now
h3 doesn't completely stop the marshal
bishop to d7 is an idea and after the c3
d5
again however if you're black and
haven't studied this this can catch you
off guard because now after standard
marshall moves
um capturing on e5 isn't good for whites
but the idea is after like bishop to d6
and rook to uh
as rook takes d5 you can't just go with
your standard plans now
instead of taking on e5 white should
just play d3 they have a completely fine
game but
this is different than the martial
attack
we do have a question about eight
a4 or i guess
yeah eight a4 instead of uh
h3 here and this is known as the
anti-marshal so if black tries to go d5
here
you just take on b5 and they can't take
back because it hangs the rook
and their knight is attacked so they
don't get this
this crazy attack right away they should
probably take on e4
to counter the threat of taking on c6
but after these trades queen f3
i'd say this is much more preferable
black does not get the insane
development that they get
with a knight coming to d5 a bishop on
d6 and queen h4
is you know how are you going to get
black to get these moves
on the board in this position so
the marshall attack will not work after
a4 that's why
after a4 here is known as the
anti-marshal
and moves to be considered would be
bishop to b7
that way after the capture on b5 you can
recapture with bishop or queen
or i believe more common is just pawn to
b4
and after pawn to a5 this is going to be
the structure you get and this has its
own set of ideas that we're not going to
get into tonight
this is its own its own opening here
um sandra shock is mentioning 9 e4
is an off guard weapon though dubious i
believe he mentioned it earlier was
um sam shankland mentioned
something about it with um
i'd say after d5 takes and then
i'm assuming it's e4 here nine e4
but let's see what the idea is after
takes on c6 take on f3
um it looks like instead of queen takes
f3
that's met with bishop to g4 and black
gets some serious play
but it looks like you can get away with
playing g3
shutting down the play here you're gonna
go pawn to d4 and then you're gonna pile
up on this f3 pawn
in the future
we have another question about the
anti-marshal here after
a4 bishop to b7
uh pawn to c3
and then d5 is it bad for black or why
is it bad
i don't think this is bad because white
shouldn't be playing c3 here
um this is uh edward a in the youtube
chat after a4
bishop b7 c3
d5 bad for black i i can't agree
um this is fine this is how black should
be playing white should not be playing
c3 after playing a4
all right i'm going to check in with the
twitch chat see if there's any updates
over there
um chesweeb saying i'm refuting the
marshall
i can't refute the marshall the
marshall's too good
probably dennis who's putting that in
the chat there
although if danish boros would like to
come and refute the marshall i'd love to
see it
and then russell is mentioning here in
the youtube chat
that after a4 black went d5 and one
so like yeah d5 is not bad for black
and then uh last question i'll answer
here in the youtube chat is why are
there so many moves of opening theory
for this but not for other openings
um probably has to go back to the
history of this opening
it was said that marshall prepared this
attack
for up to the number of varies anywhere
between
seven and an entire decade uh yeah seven
to ten
years that this attack was developed for
capablanca
so i would imagine that over ten years
uh marshall had a lot of theory for what
white could play
now after the original game this
was a very serious attack by black and
if white goes wrong
or white plays some inaccurate move it
can go south very quickly miniatured
so it's almost necessary this this
attack or this gambit was was too
strong uh to just kind of let it sit by
him
just passively you know you don't want
to be like um
okay let's say if i don't study the
alakin i can probably still get a good
game against an alakan
against uh average tournament player
even if i haven't studied it
but here against the marshall it is a
very serious attack you do need to be
prepared for it if you're playing
c3 in tournament games that would be why
i would assume it's
so much theory it's just it was such a
strong attack white has so many options
but you need to be very precise so lots
of good questions from the chat a very
interactive chat
tonight which always makes it more
enjoyable i want to thank everyone for
coming
to the openings explained lecture we are
here at the end of our time
this was the martial attack if you guys
are interested in more of the
anti-martial theory
or any other openings once this video
gets published to youtube just drop it
in the comment section below
i always take recommendations from there
we're going to move over to twitch where
we're going to continue
our multi-part series called the
winner's circle what that is is we take
a look at tournaments in history
and follow the games of the win of the
winner
the tournament we're looking at now is
the 53 zurich candidates
where we're looking at the games of the
victor vasily smithslav
so we're going to cover round seven
through 10 over there in just a few
seconds
again thanks for stopping out i'm nick
risco i'll see you guys next week for
openings explained
you